bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors une
sincérité altéré car le scrutin s'est
fait sans le peuple premiers
ont déclaré plusieurs membres du palika
réunir en conférences qui ont donc
déposé un recours devant le conseil
d'état pour contester le résultat de ce
référendum corps et âme finalement les
indépendantistes
d'abord celle que ce recours n'est pas
une surprise les indépendantistes
avaient annoncé qu'ils contesteraient au
plan légal au plan politique un peu les
deux plans en même temps aussi
le les résultats du troisième référendum
donc là c'est chose faite après une
première mission conduite par un
dirigeant de l'ugt c'est monsieur roch
wamytan auprès de l'onu il ya quinze
jours c'est le palika qui déposent un
recours devant le conseil d'état et il y
aura une race un terrain certainement
d'autres
évidemment ce que contestent les
indépendantistes c'est la tenue de ce
référendum alors que il prône l
abstention et que la moitié des
électeurs
plus de la moitié des électeurs ont
suivi cette consigne dont une écrasante
majorité naturellement
d'électeurs indépendantiste
donc la contestation porte sur le fait
que le référendum doit consulter la
population intéressée et que ce n'est
pas complètement le cas et surtout ça
n'est pas le cas pour une majorité
d'électeurs
mélanésiens donc la population
autochtone de ce pays
à votre avis ce recours at il des
chances d'être validé par le conseil
d'état on sait qu'il ya d'autres recours
un qui pourrait être déposé ce que cela
pourrait changer changer quelque chose
je ne sais pas c'est la matière est
délicate et pointue la sincérité
électorale c'est la liberté c'est le
secret la liasse il ya une appréciation
peut être aussi un peu politique là donc
c'est difficile à dire surtout que le
conseil d'état a été saisi avant
quelques jours avant le référendum
par un groupe de citoyens qui demandait
son son report qui contestait la date et
la tenue du scrutin et que ce recours
n'a pas abouti positivement donc c'est
difficile à dire mais ça fait partie de
l'arsenal
des armes politiques utiliser un
nouvelle calédonie de façon assez
régulière d'ailleurs les partis
politiques les institutions ont
l'habitude sur des sujets qu'ils
estiment est important de poser des
recours soit auprès du conseil d'état
soit auprès du tribunal administratif
dans un communiqué un le palika qui a
d'ailleurs rappelé que cette
consultation du 12 décembre met fin à la
série détroit référendum prévu par les
accords de nouméa mais elle ne met en
aucun cas un terme au processus de
décolonisation je cite un ni au droit
inaliénable du peuple de la nouvelle
calédonie à l'autodétermination et à
l'indépendance
est-ce que là c'est le début d'un
nouveau bras de fer est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à d'autres actions de la part
des indépendantistes
pas forcément parce que
qui va peut être étonné ce point fait
l'unanimité
tous les partis politiques en nouvelle
calédonie savent que
l'autodétermination est toujours vivante
au plan juridique était au plan
politique naturellement
de la question c'est quand et comment
maintenant que les trois référendum
prévu par l'accord de nouméa ont eu lieu
c'est d'ailleurs une des dimensions
importantes des négociations qui qui
s'annonce et le palika par le peuple le
calédonien parce que justement l'acquis
de l'accord de nouméa c'est d'avoir
tenté et réussi en partie un mariage
politique entre le peuple premier et les
autres ceux qui sont à iv donc c'est cet
acquis politiques là qui n'est remis en
cause par personne par aucun parti
politique
important nouvelle calédonie et qui
obtient un soutien populaire dont parmi
tous les catégories d'électeurs qu'il
soit indépendantiste ou non
indépendantiste et donc la difficulté
est de continuer dans cette direction du
mariage politique qui a commencé avec
l'accord de nouméa dans le cadre du
droit à l'autodétermination qui est
pérenne en somme
y compris dans le droit constitutionnel
français est naturellement au plan
international merci beaucoup en tout cas
il se met curkovic d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
historien et spécialiste de la nouvelle
calédonie à contemporaine